bonjour je m'appelle diego et merci pour
nous accepter dans le france réception
sous les ors de l'hôtel groslot pour ces
collégiens de la nouvelle orléans ils
sont 25 élèves à participer aux
jumelages et il parle pour la plupart un
excellent français
ils sont dans une école d'immersion et
du coup il y parle français depuis
qu'ils sont en maternelle en fait est
qu'ils sont tous leurs cours en français
sauf les cours d'anglais et du coup
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont une très bonne
compréhension du français au programme
de la dizaine de jours qu'ils vont
passer à orléans des visites de la
maison de jeanne d'arc de chambord mais
aussi des cours l'après midi avec leurs
correspondants du collège jean pelletier
j'aime sur des places historiques
j'aime ma culture et tous les choses à
manger
personnellement c'est un plaisir de les
recevoir chine parce qu'ils nous font
découvrir plein de trucs
moi je suis vraiment content parce que
je tombais sur un correspondant qui est
en fait un peu comme moi qui a vraiment
les mêmes coûts et puis une passion pour
la musique et vu que de la même passion
le jumelage avec la nouvelle orléans
suscite beaucoup d'enthousiasmé de part
et d'autre de l'atlantique
c'est la spontanéité des américains
alors la seiva là dans la rue enfin
partout on allait la spontanéité
l'accueil qu'elle très chaleureux et
puis surtout cette couleur qu'il y a il
ya de la musique tout le temps du matin
au soir et les élèves du collège jean
pelletier espère bientôt pouvoir s'en
rendre compte par eux-mêmes
et oui car entre orléans et la nouvelle
orléans c'est une longue histoire
démarrée il ya trois siècles déjà une
histoire qui nous est racontée ce soir
par flavien texier bonsoir flavien
bonsoir rebecca oui vous l'avez dit
trois siècles et une première date à
retenir 1718 la création de la nouvelle
orléans dont vous découvrez en ce moment
des images le nom de cette ville a été
choisi en l'honneur du régent philippe
alors duc d'orléans le voici les points
communs entre ces deux villes sont
nombreux tout deux sont traversés bien
sûr par un fleuve la loire à orléans le
mississippi à la nouvelle-orléans
références historiques également avec
jeanne d'arc dont on célèbre là-bas la
naissance chaque 6 janvier depuis
maintenant 10 ans et puis aussi et puis
aussi la musique avec la cité johannique
qui va découvrir le jazz avec l'arrivée
des américains en 1917 lors de la
première guerre mondiale
1917 et bien c'est justement une date
très importante cette année là la
nouvelle orléans organise la célébration
de son bicentenaire est là bas et bien
il ya un petit groupe de personnes qui
veut renouer des liens avec la france
une délégation est alors reçu en octobre
à l'occasion d'une visite officielle à
l'hôtel groslot par le maire d'orléans
de l'époque un certain fernand rabier et
c'est alors le début d'une longue longue
amitié qui commence et cela va continuer
par la suite bien sûr et ces échanges
vont se poursuivre dans
l'entre-deux-guerres puis dans les
années 60 ils vont se renforcer sous
l'impulsion d'un autre maire roger
secrétin passionné par l'amérique et par
l'urbanisme de la nouvelle orléans il va
d'ailleurs largement s'en inspirer pour
créer une ville nouvelle orléans 2 qui
deviendra par la suite est bien le
fameux quartier de la source que l'on
connaît tous toujours dans les années 60
roger ce crétin que l'on va voir à
l'image voilà
financera par ailleurs une large partie
de la statue de jeanne d'arc qui est
installé là-bas depuis cette époque
enfin rebecca vous l'avez compris
beaucoup d'initiatives elles sont
nombreuses et pourtant il faudra
attendre janvier 2018 pour que soit
enfin officialisé le principe d'un
jumelage
une délégation vous le voyez emmenée par
olivier carré était sur place en début
d'année un siècle après avec a une
histoire très riche merci beaucoup
flavien